If you are not a
nudist, style is for you.
I've been in the fashion and
styling business for 20 years.
Most people know me
from "Queer Eye."
I've probably helped
literally thousands of people
find their personal
style and find
a look that makes them
feel good about themselves.
I want you to look
in your closet
and decide, who do I want to be?
What do I want to feel?
I just want you
to make an effort.
This class is different from
anything I've ever done before.
I will comprehensively
break down what style is
and how the principles work.
American men, plaid is not
your only option for a print.
Move on.
It is absolutely
possible for you
to have great style
on any budget.
The key is a capsule wardrobe.
This is your base.
This is your foundation.
All of these items could be worn
time after time and reimagined.
I devoted my life to style
because it affected me so
greatly as a child.
I so desperately wanted to
show who I really was inside,
but I couldn't because of
my culture and my faith.
When I was seven, I went
to my granddad's factory.
He made denim.
And for the first
time, I understood
where clothes came from,
how they were created,
and how they could make me feel.
And so I started to
experiment with clothes,
and my clothes gave me a
window into the world that I
could only have dreamt of.
I want you to
really start to see
your closet as a
vehicle to getting
what you want from your life.
I want you to really
feel something
when you get dressed
in the morning.
Every day, know that
you've made an effort.
Be the reason that you're happy.
I'm Tan France, and
this is my MasterClass.
[MUSIC PLAYING]